sure germany won the World Cup but they
want it with six guys who all play for
Bayern Munich the reigning bundesliga
champions as usual the national team is
Bayern plus it's an advertisement for a
club team you see an immediate impact of
interest in guts and Muller these people
who want how to do it never had before
so many requests from TV networks and
radio stations and nobody here in the UM
us as well you said actually in Germany
and in the US and the club was already
prepared to do something with this
exposure fired open the business office
in New York this summer once American
fans and it wants American revenue we
have 60 million people interested in
soccer and 15 million people interested
in by meaning it's actually a pretty
huge target and how do you take somebody
who's interested in turn him into a fan
we just launched our new us online store
we have off the way of launched our us
website so we definitely offer a US
related content we definitely wanna get
in touch with them of all the soccer
teams in the world Bayern ranks third in
revenue it's behind only real madrid and
FC barcelona by earns three main
sponsors t-mobile adidas and audi
together own a quarter of the franchise
this us push is in part the sponsors
ideal there tina has a big follow their
team has a lot of exposure they are
going to come back to america more and
more often and that's a really smart
thing for us to be along for the ride
for
Americans don't have to start watching
Germany's Bundesliga for this to work
Bayern is also part of the elite
champions league with teams that already
have a following here Spain's Real
Madrid the UK's Liverpool and Audi
doesn't even have to make Americans love
soccer it just has to get to the ones
who already do what Rick car market is
about ten percent of the total market
audi is about one percent of the total
market so we're not looking at mass mass
influence looking at targeted smart
influence if you look at it where it's
popular and what communities in what
town you see sounds like Seattle it's
like Portland loads of town so we have
15 points of market share these are out
each house Byron is chasing success the
UK's Barclays Premier League doubled its
TV viewership last year it said
attendance records on a summer tour but
the Bavarians think there's a US market
for more leads and definitely for more
teams be enough competing and it is kind
of additional but the market is so big
and I'll tell everybody come to the
space and how sports growing